the anti-masters are getting even more
disgusting if you can imagine that
at hawthorne elementary school in
beverly hills california
a group of anti-masters showed up with
signs and flyers
protesting mask rules and they are
accosting
children at school they're accosting
kids telling them among other things
don't wear the mask
the mask smells bad the mask is bad
these are kids doing what their parents
and the school have decided they're
going to do
and the protesters show up and tell them
not to wear masks let's look at one clip
it's visual mostly but you'll also just
from listening get
a little bit of a sense of the
[Music]
atmosphere
[Music]
um
they are handing out flyers to children
and in this next clip you will actually
hear
a a protester telling a kid i'm sure you
hate that mask i'm sure it smells bad
don't wear it
[Music]
sometimes you do something that isn't
that fun because it's what the rules are
and because of some greater good i'm the
first one to say
i don't think the outdoor masking has
ever made sense and we're now hearing
from more medical doctors who are
basically saying the same thing
but the indoor masking does make a
difference
and aside from the depraved nature of
telling kids to ignore the health
guidelines
that a school has established don't they
realize that these are children
it is incredibly intimidating for adults
to show up
and talk to kids like this and yell
stuff at them and one of the impressions
i got from watching video of the
protesters
is that there's a real kind of like q
anon
stop the steel type energy or vibe
to these people not just their physical
appearance which is definitely part of
it but just the demeanor everything
about it
and i was looking around at different
commentaries on this and
john scott railton from the university
of toronto
tweeted about the exact same thing
saying quote context some may find
interesting a lot of stop the steel
movement energy
ditto q anon has poured into acts and
anti-vaccine agitating prepare for more
of this kind of thing and of course it's
borne out in the numbers
we know that 43 percent of republicans
don't want to get the vaccine they are
some of the primary drivers of the
anti-vaccine sentiment in addition
we know that both russia and china are
operating on social media to foment
anti-vaccine sentiment and of course as
the 2016 election showed us and
other examples um older right-wingers
are the most likely to fall for
amplifying
um what i would call destabilizing
propaganda from foreign countries and of
course what better way to destabilize
the us
than to encourage people not to do the
one thing that will get us out of the
pandemic which is
get vaccinated now there are lots of
questions about whether this type of
quote protest is protected by the first
amendment
as a general principle it is showing up
there and holding signs that say no
masks or whatever
but one might imagine that when it comes
to starting to yell at children
at their school when it comes to
strangers approaching kids at school
doesn't it go over into harassment
certainly standing there not blocking
the sidewalk holding an anti-mask sign
absolutely no question about that but
they also appear to sort of be blocking
the sidewalk
they may be interfering with kids
getting in and out of school they're
yelling at children and of course
if anyone tried to shut them down they
would immediately say this is the
government
silencing us taking our first amendment
right
i'm not even suggesting they be shut
down
it's better to tell the kids to ignore
them maybe even set up a way to get kids
in and out of school
without being subject to this i have no
idea if that's possible given the layout
but is there no limit to this where
we're now talking about
yelling at children harassing little
kids about masks
maybe there should be some buffer zone
law
like there is with campaigning at
polling places where sure listen you
have a first amendment right
you can campaign for whoever you want
you can hold signs but on election day
you have to be a certain distance from
where people are voting otherwise it
could be considered intimidation
maybe there's something with school
schools as well because we're talking
about kids i don't know i'm thinking
out loud here they're almost turning the
school
into the same type of gauntlet that
anti-abortion activists activists will
try to turn
the entrance area to a medical clinic
for women considering an abortion it's
it's a similar type of harassment except
more vile
because these are children who are going
by what their parents
and school officials are saying are
going to be the rules
as a country when you see video
of anti-masters yelling at children
and harassing kids at school that
doesn't bode well for the united states
as a country when you see that that's a
red flag that things may be going in a
very bad
direction um let me know your thoughts
we're going to have more coverage of
this on our instagram page you can find
the david pakman show on instagram at
davidpakmanshow
you can also find me on instagram
david.pakman
one of our sponsors is curiositystream
letting my audience
try it free for an entire month
curiositystream is a streaming service
offering thousands of documentaries from
some of the world's
best filmmakers including exclusive
originals and curiosity stream is just
like
the netflix for documentaries it's
perfect
for anybody who loves politics history
science just documentaries
in general i've been watching a ton of
curiosity stream i can watch on my tv
my phone my tablet and one of the first
things i noticed
about curiositystream is that these are
high quality documentaries
not the cheap documentaries on many
other streaming services
i've noticed curiosity stream has the
biggest and newest titles
from the most respected documentary
filmmakers
my favorite so far has been what is
reality by david eagleman i've read his
books and the documentary
is fantastic curiosity stream is just
299 a month or
19.99 for a whole year but my audience
can try it free
for a month when you go to
curiositystream.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman